and a good evening to you at 11 I'm
Brian Loftis a week after the FBI
released documents on the one October
shooter letter sent to him prior to the
2017 Massacre suggests that he discussed
his plan with ex-friend and ex-convict
Jim Nixon Sasha Loftus went through the
documents tonight joining us live in
studio with our top story Brian these
letters which are dated between
and 2017. so suggests that Stephen
Paddock shared plans to hurt others his
friend begging him to get help a few
months before the shooting now warning
some may find this information
disturbing
[Music]
after the FBI released more documents
about the one October shooter we have
another look at what happened months
before Stephen Paddock killed 58 people
and heard hundreds more at the Route 91
Harvest Festival in 2017.
these letters between Paddock and
ex-convict Jim Nixon who refers to the
two as friends also shares his concern
in one dated May 27 2017 Nixon says
Paddock quote sounded like a madman on
the phone he then says he believes
Paddock is going to commit a shooting
writing please don't go out shooting or
hurting innocent people who did nothing
to you in another passage Nixon goes on
to say Paddock should turn himself in
for quote the murder he told him he
committed in 2012. Nixon then says are
you telling me the truth did you really
kill a person for practice several other
letters include Nixon begging Paddock to
not go on a shooting rampage with one
saying what kind of killing are you
going to do and why concerts Nixon also
makes many references to paddock's
weapons saying he has been buying them
like a quote four-star general who was
about to start a war several letters
also ending with him asking Paddock to
please get help and quote tell him his
plans and talk to someone
now you'll remember two people also died
from their shooting injuries at a later
time we have more on the letters and the
report released by the FBI in March on
our website 8newsnow.com